para este tercer y último partido de
fase de grupos de Francia y diez de show
decidió alinear un equipo Beta con nueve
jugadores completamente nuevos sobre el
terreno de juego entre ellos dice así
que por primera vez usaba la camiseta de
Francia e incluso con un Eduardo
camavinga que esta vez hizo las veces de
lateral izquierdo en vez de mantenerse
en el centro como eso su posición normal
y esto se notó bastante en el campo de
juego una Francia que sufrió muchísimo a
lo largo de los primeros 45 minutos
tratando de frenar todas las ofensivas
por parte de túnez un equipo muy bien
parado muy organizado con muchísima
experiencia y esto pagó porque ya al
minuto 58 llegaría el gol después de un
despeje mal despeje de fofana la iduni
recupera la pelota la da a castrid y el
mismo El capitán el número diez es el
encargado de abrir el marcador del único
gol de este partido y dejar con vida a
túnez para los octavos de final sin
embargo pues divides son logró hacer
cambios entrar la la artillería pesada
ya con la griezmann con mbappé y esto
también se notó sobre el terreno de
juego una Francia que obtenía ya mucho
más la pelota más la creación más
incisiva e incluso griezmann empató el
partido ya sobre los últimos instantes
pero fue uno gol que terminó siendo
anulado por estar fuera del lugar en
todo caso al final de esto ya era en el
banquillo de los tunecinos Las Águilas
de Cartago estaban viendo el partido de
lo que estaba sucediendo entre el
Australia y Dinamarca y cuando ya vieron
que era Australia la que se había
quedado con esa Victoria supieron que el
esfuerzo pues no había sido suficiente
que quedaban por fuera de este mundial A
pesar de esta Victoria histórica pues
termina siendo una victoria morra amargo
como se puede decir en árabe de esta
manera pues a Francia queda primera de
este grupo de mientras que Australia
queda segunda